joining me now with reaction is ed
Mullins NYPD sergeant and president of
New York City's sergeants benevolent
association and Mark Furman Fox News
contributor in former LAPD detective
good to have you both on tonight and you
just heard the angle you've spoken with
police in the precinct who have direct
knowledge of what's going on now what I
was going through the officers heads
when this was all happening hello yeah
I'm just saying what was what was going
through their heads when this was
happening what was going through their
heads is the Pantaleo effect we've had
you know a police commissioner and an
NYPD Department several years ago send
officers to enforce a minor crime loose
cigarettes about two years ago two and a
half years ago we had a sergeant
involved in a shooting we shot a 66 year
old woman who swung at his head with a
baseball bat Police Commissioner O'Neill
came out and condemn that right away
we've seen Pantaleo for the last five
years not getting any support from the
department so the officers that are out
there on patrol now the officers at the
water being thrown on them are
indecisive in a sense of what they
should do and will they have the backing
of the NYPD how they go to make an
arrest
and this individual or any of the
individuals fell and cracked a head we'd
hear the meteor and we hear other people
out in the public saying these were
minor crimes and all of a sudden
everything would turn against these
offices there is no leadership in the
NYPD this has been a problem we've had
three cops assassinated several cops
killed we have numerous cops shot there
is there's absolutely no leadership in
the NYPD and none coming from City Hall
and I'm asking Police Commissioner
O'Neal with empathy in my heart that you
have lost the confidence the NYPD
members and to please resign now in the
interest of Public Safety in the
interests of the safety of the officers
it's time for you to move on not resign
I am asking mayor de Blasio to make one
good to see in a mayoral term and to
remove this police commissioner
go you've lost the confidence of the
NYPD alright let's go to mark fuhrman I
mark I won't hold my breath
about de Blasio doing the right thing I
mean if anything he'll condemn you know
the you know the police for not giving
the you know the people who are laughing
like a soft drink or sometimes I don't
know he's not do anything but mark you
take issue with the fact that at the
moment at that time the police didn't do
anything but aren't they damned if they
do and they're damned if they don't in
this situation well if you actually feel
that way you need a new job there's
never been a time when politicians or
Chiefs or captains or even lieutenants
are going to be at a scene and actually
agree with what actually needs to be
done
they usually hesitate the perfect
example is any demonstration we watch it
in Portland we watch it in New York we
watch it in Los Angeles times are
changing because they're hesitating to
engage these two officers looked
ridiculous in what they did they should
have as soon as they were assaulted they
have that suspect in the car they should
have put out an assistance call they
should have turned and actually engage
the suspect if they get into an
altercation that's fine if they have to
use their tasers that's fine if they
have to use force other than that that's
fine because the next officer that goes
in that neighborhood maybe he'll get a
bucket of paint maybe a bucket of bleach
maybe even some acid this is this is a
job that is tough and if you're not
willing to engage this wasn't a decision
by some somebody in an ivory tower this
wasn't a captain's decision or a police
commissioner this was the two officers
on the street they were in charge of
this situation and they did nothing yeah
it's got it's got to be incredibly
demoralizing for police officers and I
know talking to a number of them over
the last 24 hours since we were the
first to put this video on national TV
they are infuriated across a number of
different issues now late tonight NYPD
released pictures of three of the
suspects in these water attacks also
NYPD is notifying officers about the
charges
that can be brought against these thugs
so it's exactly what former NYPD
Commissioner Bernie Kerik told us last
night watch obstruction disorderly
conduct harassment and the number of
other charges but they won't be charged
because you have a mayor in New York
City that wants a disgrace and what
chance do they have of actually catching
and charging these guys and you agree
with mark Fuhrman's analysis that as
tough as this job is if the officers
don't want to engage on the scene they
should no longer be police officers go
into a different line of work
god bless them well I think there's
partial truth what Mark is explaining
but mark comes from a different time
period when policing was supported and
there was no cameras that would be in
stuck in everybody's faces and you know
when I highlight the Pantaleo effect
that Chiefs ordered these officers to go
out and enforce minor crimes of loose
cigarettes where is the backing for the
people who do that so it's easy for us
to say what officers should do but we're
not the ones that are there when it
happens and we're not the officers we're
getting indicted because of you know
public outcry over nonsense so it's it's
very easy to be opinionated from one
side of a fence but mark and I both come
from different time periods and I'm
still there and I see what's occurring
in policing today mark responds well I
mean that's all well and good but I can
remember many times that I wasn't
supported by the chief of police and on
down because we actually engaged
multiple people that were trying to
assault us rocks bottles gunshots but we
still engaged we called for assistance
and yes it got ugly but you didn't lose
your ground and you didn't walk away
with your tail between your legs if
you're gonna do that just give up the
streets you be on the O'Neil we're now
promoting videos of basically dancing
bears and karaoke singing contests out
there now we've gone from enforcement
we've gone from a paramilitary
organization to a feel-good and we've
spent energy and millions of dollars on
creating a feel-good to the point where
offices are getting indicted
nonsense and they're not getting the
back in the knee my PD wants to go I
want to I want to put this video this
full screen up for everyone in the
country to see now look at what this
current atmosphere has done to
recruitment of police officers check it
out
NYPD recruitment it's down down down
okay it's only at three hundred and
thirty people as far as as of April 2019
look at where it was back in July of
2017 524 January 2018 they did pretty
well but doesn't look so good right now
mark what what's next for recruitment
they can't hire police officers in
places like New Orleans last time I
checked other places across the country
same thing well there's certain places
that the law enforcement should be at
the highest standards it should be Los
Angeles it should be New York it should
be a few other cities but the actual the
the the heart of the matter is
leadership and if you don't have a good
leader it doesn't matter what people in
the community think law enforcement
should be a good leader will give them
the law enforcement that they need and
if you're going to engage with bad
actors on the street you need to engage
if you don't we're not going to worry
about it officer get indicted somebody's
gonna get killed
suspects are gonna get killed and
officers are gonna get killed this is
just one step the next one will be more
than water because they got away with it
and the disrespect of the police and for
each other all of I mean it is all
ridiculous at this point gentlemen
fantastic conversation and when I was
having this on television tonight thank
you so much